alors bonjour je suis justin de france
bonjour je suis clemi snow et nous
allons faire le commentaire audio de à
voir absolument
oui je tiens à m'excuser parce que je
suis malade et je suis en extinction de
voix
en pleine récupération d'où cette voix
étrange oui et du coup j'ai pas parler
trop fort pour construire le problème
niveau mais pour le moins voix sexy et
sensuelle faisons un petit peu de smr
sinon il se passe des choses à l'écran
donc ça c'est l'épisode zéro dont on a
eu l'idée parce que on s'est dit que
peut-être que les gens qui n'ont pas
qu'ils n'ont jamais je chronique de
profs ne comprendront pas qu'ils sont
radiées nord le chrétien que nous joue
puisque les minots égale le chrétien les
aliénor égale mois donc on a fait cet
épisode zéro qui est d'ailleurs très
drôle même si je ne suis pas dedans on
l'a tourné un an après leur est aussi
parce que il ya eu toute la partie
montage postproduction et après on s'est
dit tiens si on faisait ça d'ailleurs ça
se voit pas ce que tu n'as pas du tout
la même longueur de cheveux ni la même
couleur mais c'est sympa ce sens est
très drôle c'est sûr net vous avez bien
repris les codes des émissions nulles
c'était le but donc si ça vous paraît
nul c'est normal oui c'est ça qu'on veut
mais c'est drôle du coup fort moi ça m'a
fait rire ouais bah c'est ça l'idée
c'était de faire la prof à des personnes
qu'elle reçoit chez elle mais qui sont
est là que se passe-t-il
ça c'était drôle avec l'histoire de
l'humanité genre à calais nord qui
découvre des choses sur la victoire elle
fume est il était une fois la vie
jamais je ne l'avais pas assez d'eau
mais après j'arrive sur la dinosaures je
crois et l'imagerie des dinosaures non
oui je crois que c'est ça avoir fait
j'adore
comment sont ils arrivés parmi nous et
qu'elle attend elle s'est quand même
allumé une souris à l'époque mais il ya
eu des plans avant où elle galérait où l
utiliser l'eau de javel avis arrêté et
après je me faisais après on montre
qu'elle a évolué parce que maintenant
oui ça fait quand même quelques mois
qu'elle vit dans cette époque j'ai dit
un gros mot c'est grave
tu seras censuré ok je mettrais un bip
oui bip c'est trop tard mais l'intention
était bonne
oui la voilà c'était un bon épisode
voilà je suis désolé si je tousse
régulièrement et c'est parti pour
l'épisode 1 et c'est toi c'est moi je
suis très déçu qu'on n'ait pas dit
stephan bureau
oui c'est une censure honteuse de notre
seconde réalisatrice mais c'est tant pis
et on peut noter que tu es en train de
lire le livre
oracle qui est très bien oui écrit par
justin morvan mais on en est au
troisième tome qui vient de sortir
alors je ne sais pas il faut l'acheter
il faut savoir que je suis avachi sur ce
canapé et ça m'allait bien parce que je
venais de me faire une entorse à la
cheville
genre la veille jean la veille du
tournage mais ouais t'as plutôt bien
géré ça j'ai la vie allongée donc ça va
du coup toute l'équipe et avec de chez
moi vers minuit oui c'est ça fait tout
le temps tu sors d urgence à c'était
chouette ça c'est un générique toi tu
vas bien parce qu'est la musique a été
faite par valentin au je suis zen
oui et les graphismes ont été faits
aussi pas à oublier le nom de notre
second graphiste ces paraphes ecafé ça
n'a pas bougé sont en plus elle est dans
aller dans le générique de toute façon
mais elle nous a fait ces deux ces deux
illustrations en style vitraux qui sont
très jolies je sais même pas ce que
c'est un pilote de guerre un pilote
c'est une arme très bien mais comme on
dit enterré la hache de guerre mais
qu'elle est les romaines je me suis dit
aïe ça marche
peut-être que personne n'a été choqué
mais moi sur toute cette séquence
je suis dépité par la façon dont mc
perruque a été coiffée
on dirait un troll avec une oreille qui
sort c'est pas joli le but était de
dégager mon visage pour pas avoir les
cheveux dans les yeux mais en fait ça
dégage juste genre l'oreille moche non
mais non c'était moi je suis pas
d'accord je suis pas content et je n'ai
pas pu de checker la coiffure avant
assez drôle parce qu'ali d'un recherche
des champignons et elle passe à côté du
seul champignons de la forêt un livre
c'est un humour vraiment subtil oui oui
c'est pour ça que j'ai strict pour les
gens qui n'ont pas compris ça c'est
godefroy ce plan est très drôle vif très
camelot oui c'était le but
j'aime bien parce qu'elle adore vraiment
très bête dans cette partie et lui il y
très condescendant
oui c'est ces instructions de jeux
étaient faits la façon où oss 117 et je
pense qu'il a plutôt réussi à me vois
que mots votre présence oui dans le
bêtisier dit que me vaut comme nouveau
votre présent oui d'investissement ça
veut rien dire c'est que momo l'honneur
de votre présence en ces lieux
oui mais c'est une abréviation oui oui
j'ai pas parlé quoi ou alors tu ne sais
pas écrire
il sait pas parler non je pense que je
l'avais écrit comme ça mais c'est fff
oui elle rouvière qui a fait les
illustrations que vous voyez au lyrique
de début et vine je crois qu'il s'agit
oui voila je savais que je connaissais
elle me l'a envoyé en mode regard jeté
dessinée or c'est moi tu savais pas que
tu la connais si je connais hélas tu as
tu rates et des tic
voilà oui je suis la seule en avoir eu
mais en même temps je suis la seule à
être adossé à un arbre donc tout se paye
et j'en suis rendu compte que le
lendemain en plus de trafic sur le bras
étrange hasard que cette brosse à dents
est toujours là oui c'est sa place
naturelle de quoi elle est l'accord très
bien elle s était déjà sa place avant le
tournage
oui mais il me semble qu'il y avait il y
avait des poussières et y avait que lors
on tire on me poussive je trouve que lui
crise est particulièrement désagréable
oui bon je tiens à dire que ce n'était
pas du tout difficile à jouer on les bat
on comprend pourquoi j'étais cassé et là
je suis bien coiffée oui pour accor donc
faux raccords non mais le temps de me
jeter sur le canapé parce que je pouvais
pas marcher mes cheveux se sont remis
naturellement d'une manière jolie oui et
si vous regardez le bêtisier vous verrez
tu te jeter de très belle manière sur le
groupe et dans les prés de beaucoup de
grâce et on n'a peut-être pas remarqué
que tu dab et en bâillant aussi il faut
préciser que justement là ça a été
enlevé et non la tude abers ben ouais
c'est pas très marqué parce qu'on m'a
dit que c'était pas bien de faire ça à
monsieur voilà cet épisode 1 s'est
échoué à être là pour la version youtube
c'est pour la wii se promettent des
finales en bien de temps du coup c'est
20 secondes 20 secondes je retiens pour
la série mais des fois elle a pas mis
leur seconde allez sur clemi snow là
nous retrouvons les aventures d'aliénor
qui est clairement la boniche de la prof
ou enfin en même temps c'est pareil au
niveau du cast c'est assez naturel pour
toi d'être à la fois amap d'être la
première à boloni ch de moi même parce
qu'il est juste de faire ma propre
réfléchir et même pokémon regardent ils
sont là bas
oui mais c'est cynthia qui me les a
donnés par faire comme toi aussi non je
suis auto - ping bref bonjour cimetière
ce coussin c'est moi qui ai offert tous
les offert à justin oui c'est bien vrai
ça c'est juste un autre script qui fait
la voix off
il fait très bien stéphane bern elle du
coup super effets spéciaux tête deux
fois sur le même plan c'est incroyable
oui mais j'ai rejoint ma soeur jumelle
oui tout à fait sinon il me semble que
tu as demandé à ta super copine qu'amis
no comment tu faisais pourra faire deux
plans tu m'avais demandé une fois oui je
te l'avais dit en vo la verticale oui
mais là du coup c'est par voler
verticale a fait ces nouvelles
informations sauf estime marie chacun
son truc écoute chacun son niveau là que
j'ai mangé un oui j'en ai mangé
tellement pour cette prise noailles
départ du tour et aussi
quand tu dis un cerf tu parles de
l'animal exactement ce qu'il fait parce
brute la pratique toutes affaires
s'affaisse bruit là non quand ils
bramwell web un jeu bram bien oui oui
oui
là j'avais beaucoup de texte à dire oui
c'était très fatiguant d'ailleurs godman
ans est fou c'est faux au contraire je
suis très professionnel et de chez moi
de la publ non mais c'est vrai je suis
comédienne en attente de contrat donc
n'hésitez pas oui bah pareil mais non
c'est vrai que tu as été très bien
choisi pour le rôle je trouve ta les
très bonnes expressions âgées un visage
très expressif et j'ai des sourcils
sentais pas sa source est très expressif
al adha ineris plus fin que dani reese
oui mais tout autant mobile volubile
voulu bref du coup on apprend des choses
sur l'a6b restoria valentin m'avait fait
remarquer c'est marrant parce que du
coup il ya à chaque fois un épisode où
il se passe des trucs un peu un bien à
lyon explique et je sais bien un truc de
profs j'ai pas fait exprès mais j'ai
très bien décrit la chose quand ils se
jettent des fleurs il la soulève un
petit trou scénaristique qui ne sera pas
le seul mais on qu'on expliquera par
curieux s'impliquera pas ta gueule c'est
magique
ouais c'est ça mais les voyages en temps
oui j'ai pas voulu me prendre la tête à
1 6 jours cui les français il ya
toujours il ya toujours des bugs et ça
marche jamais dans les films donc le nom
autant pas se prendre la tête et faire
quelque chose de drôle et de ce1
patrouilles tout cas essayer pas de
chercher des théories pour expliquer sur
twitter on en a pas nous en ont quand on
n'a pas les explications qu'on les aura
peut-être dans la saison 2 ou alors on
n'était pas plus de questions donc en
moins de réponse est oui ça c'est bien
vrai
je tiens à dire que j'aime beaucoup mon
costume qui ont été cousus par ba justin
oui parce qu'avant je faisais du cosplay
et du coup je cousais des costumes donc
laissé le costume de keira knightley
week end avec l'équipe jogo nièvre dans
l'om le roi arthur 2006 pas du coaching
de romaine aux phases finales car non
parce que jouer une pics une guerrière
pickton et j'aime beaucoup
oui et là et c'est une perruque que je
porte ce ne sont pas mes vrais cheveux
oui en fait t'es mis les choses non
c'est faux mais je n'ai pas les cheveux
aussi longs du coup mais c'est moi qui
ai fait tous les costumes anciens du cos
aliénor c'est et là je viens de lâcher
mon morceau de pain comme keira
knightley dans pirates des caraïbes 1
quand elle est en train de manger dont
plus important parce que d'arrêter ça
quand elle en train de manger dans le
bateau de capitaine barbossa et qu' il
est là parce s'empoisonner et l âge son
morceau pain et j'essayais de le lâcher
paraît fou parce que tu portes un
costume qu'apporter projet l'incroyable
et du cou et le costume pas du tout
c'est cesser les di maria dans robin des
bois de ridley scott qui n'est pas
vraiment un très bon film mais j'aimais
bien le costume et la retirade basset
qui rate et pierre décarel week on verra
après on est bien car une clé en fait
oui on fauche saison 2 ont fait que des
costumes qui ont été portées en plus
j'en ai encore un balawi j'allais dire
non encore la duchesse mais j'ai
toujours aimé dire non non vous oui mais
cette séquence dans pirates des caraîbes
quand elle est en train de se goinfrer
la façon dont elle lâche le pain j'aime
la façon dont bouge ses mains et ses
doigts je suis attiré par ce genre de
détails dans les films et là ça m'a
toujours marqué et voilà mais c'est
important de pâques se concentrer que
sur son texte
non on apprend de plus en plus dans la
force de tourner et on se dit oui il
faut rajouter des choses faut vous faire
du hors texte quoi le sous-texte à et
une erreur 2g j'avais du pain dans les
mains et les mains hautes et là j'avais
les mains basses mousse pas grave
à fouras corps à corps là on voit la
nonchalance et ça c'est une référence à
doctor who allons-y alonso exactement je
tiens à dire que le fait de me suit et
la main c'était mon idée brouillé un
petit ajout improvisation d'acteur oui
je voyais bien lu crise et dédaigneuse
genre les salles je vais me laver vers
quelle horreur coronavirus tout ça intro
temps pour faire ce genre de blague
c'est pas bien je vais te sens sur rail
awards on ne crache pas dans mon micro
s'il te plaît à evelyne voilà on va le
dire dans chaque epb une roulée rc levin
et a fait détruire mais moi je suis ses
aventures sur facebook ça incroyable
tout ce qu'a fait c'est très violent
limin eurent passé des contributeurs si
les jeunes lutteurs réaliser les
contributeurs mais edwin a fait entrer
les formes oui non un travail artisanal
manuel incroyable d'anciennes techniques
des dorures des vingt fois c'est super
impressionnant
et oui elle nous montre est justement
qu'elle essayait assouad vraiment
respecter le style de l'époque soit de
l'adapter pour que ça correspondait à la
série fin à la ferme on travaille là
dessus
épisode 3 là on est à paris on était
dans le nord jusqu'à présent mais par
magie nous sommes à paris
et parce qu'on n'avait pas enfin je
t'aime plus jolies rues et ont tourné à
paris comme la plupart de l'équipe était
à paris ça c'est jihad il est très
gentil
voilà même si là on dirait pas
d'ancêtres y avait des gens qui
déménagent et quand on a commencé à
tourner ses mauvais temps qu'on a dû
attendre qu'il soit parti effectivement
je pense que c'était genre 1ère bienne
be mais il partait là on est de retour
dans le bar dans un bar où on n'a pas pu
tourner au final si on ya tourné le
lendemain d'accord je pensais qu'on a
fait dans un autre du panneau relancer
ce bar c'est le pmu par contre ça sur
redoublé oui mais du coup c'était pas
lou qui devait faire c'était rafiki
qu'on verra plus tard dans l'épisode
mais là tout ça c'est dur doublage et
c'est pour ça que la plupart des
dialogues sont de dos parce que il y
avait trop de bruit ça c'est moi qui ai
fait ce truc sur sur paint et hull a
redoublé en mode the room oui aussi jean
price-mars un quick halal de peut-être
que je la mettrais sur youtube
je ne sais pas et donc là celle où c'est
notre corps et al ceara qui devait donc
jouer la serveuse mais ce regard des
mois ses yeux
qu'ils sont bons je suis amoureuse des
yeux de raffi et grafite également
graphiste c'est elle qui a fait les
graphismes de la fiche de cette affiche
que je tiens dans les mains de la
jaquette du dvd de plein de choses
elle a fait oui il est aussi à toutes
les miniatures des épisodes donc
vraiment raf il gère sa ligne de texte
est tellement drôle où il pour lui faire
un don pour acheter un rom cd live c'est
notre ingé son qui ne s'est pas beaucoup
forcer pour son rôle non il est resté
très ça c'est juste un dos tres creed
on rigole on l'attendait à 20 litres au
cou et oui justin aussi oui tout le
monde est bien dans cette équipe ça sert
au bar notre régisseur en finlande au
régisseur faut savoir que sur ses plans
aussi raffy tient les branches d'arbres
peut-être pas dans le champ moi je
n'étais pas là à ce moment là celle qui
risquait d'être devant nous en avons
kharafi derrière qui est en train de
tenir plusieurs branches ces pratiques
tu vas mettre la version sous titre fin
la version commentée sur youtube oui je
pense
et là je n'avais jamais les gens qui
vont dvd d'iron man a menti la passante
vénère pas sans trop s installer dans
l'espace 500 la relance
oui tu as vraiment mis des trucs
intéressants dans ce but
cette musique c'est aussi donc c'est le
thème principal de la série et c'est
aussi la musique de mes chroniques de
profs qui est une musique du film le
retour de martin guerre à la base mais
que du coup valentin a réadapté fin
d'ailleurs c'est bien c'est une belle
faucheux et bien non les abonnés non
mais oui cool voilà voilà un faucon mais
20 secondes par que je voulais partir
sur a comme le monde est petit ah oui
pas de nom pas là et vous êtes 4 c'est
parti maintenant tennessee de ce bar
d'où j'étais habillée comme ça dans
paris où il 0 honte
rien à [ __ ] là le dodo et 2 face c'est
pas les mêmes lieux parce qu'on a dû
retourner ces plans là le lendemain oui
c'est vrai donc en fait là on n'est pas
du tout de vente et les sites chasse
barre et après tu sais quoi je me
réveille pas en fait ça me fait ça oui
justin aura plus pentue et de juin nous
aurons ces défauts je vois jamais non je
blague du cidre orient des failles année
le dernier jour de tournage
il est fatigué aussi et une bouteille de
rhum et on va rencontrer la pirate et
notre barman qui pourrait vous voyez ce
livre pôle nord qui a une importance par
la suite et si vous regardez bien le
décor il ya aussi un portrait de
cuillères et ça c'est une référence
là là et là c'est du hip hop mais je
sais du harry potter oui au début harry
potter vries et lui c'est la devise
d'harry potter il ne faut pas titiller
un dragon qui dort et d'ailleurs tous
les trucs en latin que je dis clairement
dans le texte écrit dit un truc en latin
je me suis dit heureusement que j'ai
fait oui bah c'est parce que j'ai fait
latin aussi donc ça c'est flou mais ce
bonjour florence bonjour flots
commencent à côté d'elle il ya une
chouette mais malheureusement la voie
perdue chez eux partout
oui si vous regardez le making off vous
la verrez mais je me disais que c'était
marrant qu'elle est comme un perroquet
pour les pirates non parce que je sais
que j'avais juste une fausse chouette
donc j'ai pris une fausse chouette
et de quoi les pas du tout autre de
boire du rhum évidemment une boîte de
l'ice tea
oui c'est pour ça qu'on voit des petites
bulles à la surface parfois je t'en prie
donc maintenant j'attends les dans ce
bar y avait du bruit avait des frigos
qu'ils aient dit oui enfin on a un peu
galéré pour le son oui tu disais oui
dont je revenais sur mon latin tout au
début genre dans le premier épisode je
dis un truc en latin ce je crois que ces
galets à cette aune isiwis à une partie
stress
c'est le début de la guerre des goals en
matin écrit par müller c'est vrai quoi
la sent pourtant lui dire ça veut dire
que la gaule est divisée en trois
parties
ça n'a rien à voir et que je fais le
blick mais c'était du latin et c'est
toujours bon pour votre culture voilà et
c'est ce que mon prof de latin m'a fait
apprendre ça en cinquième tout le
premier paragraphe de la guerre des
gaules et julian je me rappelle encore
parce que j'ai une mémoire inutile
il faut savoir aussi que cette table
était extrêmement koh lanta la fin oui
parce qu'on a mis beaucoup de dice ti
partout
d'ailleurs on avait fait un entonnoir en
papier je crois que oui vous revoir rire
remplir en avait fait des des petits
trèbes reconnaît que la jauge pour
papier de faux raccords je pense qu'il y
en a mais pas trop j'aimais mon bandana
beaucoup trop mais je trouve sur wii les
choux
oui on dirait une bikeuse maintenant que
tu lis on voit que ça mais si tu l'avais
pas dit on l'aurait pas vu oui mais moi
je suis réservé y goûte on puisse
apparemment c'est dégueulasse qu'elle
vivait parce que c'est un peu mélangé
quand même du rhum il y avait un reste
de rien reste daumail apparemment
florence au début c'est pas et qu'il
veut je la pirate elle devait de jouer
la super historiens dans tous les cas
oui on avait quelqu'un d'autre et qui
finalement a dû annuler et florence
était tellement heureuse de faire de
prendre le rôle de la pirate
je vais passer et ça lui va très bien
elle porte également une perruque oui
encore une fois il ya des trous
scénaristiques genre vous avez un doute
qui va paraître mais non c'est dans
l'épisode 5 sacks compte des motifs en
spoilers
je pense que c'est pas le premier truc
que les gens regardent le commentaire
audio ou c'est peut-être du coup ça ses
costumes des médecins dans pirates des
caraïbes on voit pas trop la mairie ne
verra après
j'aime beaucoup ce plan avec les petits
diamants et la perruque je crois que
c'est une perruque de loups pour faire
les nanas de ghostbusters oui c'est ça
quand je vais m'énerver là non c'est la
musique qui fait ça attention aux
[ __ ] c'est bon ce discours avec le
petit zoom bravard dîner zoom liberté
[Musique]
donc je sais même pas comment lier
regard des jeux très perplexes ça on a
rajouté des limes parce qu'au début
c'était vraiment appeler moi c'est
patrick le jugement dans mon regard a
beaucoup trop bois qui a vu que tu
abordes tu as bu excusez moi je
guilherme on a bu boira qui a bu boira
quais bus au d'accord qui a vu vers à
vue oui enfin je n'avais pas lui qui a
vu vers a vu les lingettes nettoyantes
ils ont tous deux être divergents des
années 95 vous connaissez oui ces vieux
oui mais je suis pas jeune je suis pas
un peu plus on a vingt secondes à
meubler merci au tennis ibère djaoui
c'était très bien ce bar le bar où bosse
et guillaume notre barman que nous
retrouverons dans l'épisode qui arrive
transition way chute gras d'ailleurs on
y fait des misères
oui il a vraiment eu mal en plus au bras
vrai super mais après dans le jour qui
venait d'un mince pas parce qu'on l'a
ligotée une florence la ligoter avec des
techniques de bondage engin c'est très
drôle
oui c'est un peu de l'impro oui complète
fin surtout de moi toi tu avais du texte
mais temporise et et gestes et moi
derrière on l'a tourné plusieurs fois
c'était toujours drôle
j'aime beaucoup les effets sonores la
petite le petit passage cedef café
mixage son et m'avait dit ouais j'ai
rajouté un petit effet pour que ça fasse
téléphone il faut dire que l'énervement
qu'on voit sur mon visage gelé tous les
jours dans mon vrai métier que je tairai
ici mais du coup c'est pas difficile à
voile à sa convoquées ça c'est tous les
jours plusieurs fois par jour et que je
m'énerve comme ça à cause de mon beats
et j'ai affaire à des êtres vivants de
moins de 10 ans voilà merci beaucoup
monsieur paul g
ça c'est la cave de chez florence dès
que des gens descendent et pourrait
allumer la lumière on était obligé
d'arrêter de tourner pour la évidemment
ces faits à des jours différents à des
endroits différents sur ça c'était le
dernier jour de tournage aussi donc on a
tourné cinq jours deux jours un jour
dans le nord et trois jours à paris là
c'était le dernier et d'y bosser ensuite
armand gros et à chaque fois il dormait
de trois orphelins parce que ouvre il
posait entre deux en plus on était trois
à dormir chez lui le pauvre
là ils étaient ligotés par les
techniques obscur île secrète de
fleurance et maquillés par raffi pour
pas non là vraiment taper ça c'est une
référence au mythe de 6,3 mais t elle
promis mais je confonds toujours en
cours mais qui je confonds toujours 6e
c'est la boule en montagne oui on
promettait qui a porté le feu aux hommes
qui étaient sur voila et donc comme les
hommes après il était en mode on est
trop fort aujourd'hui mais le feu est
tous les dieux et saufs heureux mais en
fait non du coup on va vous retirez le
feu 2 1
et puis 2-2 prométhée tu fais chier
alors ils l'ont attaché un rocher et
tous les jours il ya un faucon un aigle
qui venait lui bouffer le foie est cent
fois il repoussait donc chaque jour le
supplice recommencer et ouais elle son
frère est limité lui il était j'adore la
maîtrise il était un peu plus cool mais
il a quand même fait des trucs et du
coup pour le punir et lui ont filé une
femme trop belle et robben qui s'appelle
pandore mais 80 voilà qu avez vous en
donner une boîte en mode tu voudras pas
la boîte mais comme ils ont donné le
défaut de curiosité la meuf est en mode
ouais mais du coup j'ai quand même
l'ouvrir stocker l art lors de l'épisode
sur la mythologie grecque non plus ah
c'est ça le nouveau aux trous
scénaristiques de double donc ça va en
fait vous pouvez rester dans votre
époque je peux jouer sans parler c'est
génial oui ce n'est pas sans intérêt
sans sourciller volumineux et pim
c'est une vraie citation latine
ah oui mais c'est connu c'est césar qui
s'y trouvaient voilà mon dieu oh là là
il va s'échapper avec un skipper montre
hélas on devait être immobile sur le
plan du coup pour calais
j'avais dit je vais je me marie je meurs
je vis non oui tu as dis ça ouais j'ai
vu je vis je me marie je me produis je
meurs va on était parti en lui un
prophète ou ce qu ensemble qu'on sache
je meure jamais brûlé benoît et moi je
souhaitais absolument pas trop et
d'ailleurs je crois que mes gaz a été
coupé oui il ya des plans où il
entendait bien il ya des plans way et
j'avais ça se termine également nous on
avait fini de parler toi tu étais là je
vis je me rue et s'était de l'impro du
coup oui il y en avait déjà au dernier
épisode à la cera merci les
contributeurs oui merci contributeurs
c'est gentil vous pouvez aussi contribué
pour la saison 2 qui verra le jour
un jour elle a déjà écrit un scénario
oui j'en suis à huit c'est à dire un mii
scénario bartoli battue vauxrot tu vas
reprendre un peu parce que il y avait
des trucs genre note ça va être modifiée
peut-être non pas tant parce qu'après je
vais le travailler bientôt lyon mais
voilà il ya le squelette il ya le skull
le squelette faire passer bientôt utile
merci heureusement calais nord c'est en
plus c'est pas con comme idée oui c'est
vrai ça fait un peu plus visiteur du
futur jean louis mais visiteur du futur
que j'aime beaucoup
j'aime beaucoup aussi c'est mignon là
maintenant ça y est vous êtes veste
rouge et dans le temps
par exemple préfèrent sont
impressionnants à dire oui je voulais
vraiment faire le corps elle et on le
maquillage a été changé un peu pour
contrer que un peu de temps c'est la wii
et qui s'est fait un peu soignée du
voilà il a un petit pansement
oh oui il a des pansements aux doigts
aussi j'ai remarqué oui alors qu'avant
ils avaient du sens oh là là c'était
quand même vachement bien fait oui tout
est pensé c'est vraiment très pro là
nous sommes à l'université paris diderot
décor neutre
oui voilà parce que moi je dis déjà d'en
mettre encore louis mais pour ça que je
dis je voulais pas que ça fasse futur
puisque comme il ya des gens d'autres
époques qui viennent ils décidèrent
historiens ou veulent pas que ça fasse
futur j'aime bien cette réplique la
halle où était assis sur un fauteuil à
roulettes que l'on des syriens dans les
airs oui en même temps que le script qui
reculaient l'ingestion qui recule et on
a des problèmes de sons d'ailleurs on
n'a pas pu utiliser le la meilleure des
pistes sont pour ces plantes pour ça que
le son est moins bien
désolé et c'est toujours florence a du
coup avec ses vrais cheveux et oui c'est
fou ça c'est une salle de classe en fait
du coup c'était la vende à des joueurs
de son âge n'est revenue la veille
qu'est ce qu'on a fait le lendemain le
lendemain c'était la rue ah oui la rue
épidémie applaudir des plantes sur un
bourrage oui et j'en ai envie de faire
une alternance entre les deux scènes
l'aspect restaurer la prof et les autres
gens j'aime beaucoup et les musiques de
cet épisode aussi env est en route pour
moi j'aime bouffer voilà c'est une
romaine doha al assir godefroy
j'avais jamais remarqué le boudera d'atr
oui oui du coup on retrouve le plan de
la forêt de la musique de la forêt
puisque on revient sûr j'y allais dans
votre foi j'aime bien quand il comprend
enfin qu'ils ont baisé merde beaucoup
ton expression
[Rires]
moi je voulais faire on ne voit pas je
pas fumer mais mettre mes deux doigts
collés l'un contre l'autre et faire que
simon ils font des bisous mais ça a été
ça tu l'as fait bon maintenant en bas
près c'était pas trop le christ affermis
oui voilà avait plus tôt
ça c'est un vrai cours d'histoire la
mémoire c'est un frère points non mais
c'est vrai dans ce première sa première
saison il ya un truc sur le rapport
entre l'histoire et la mémoire qui est
légèrement soulevée évidemment ce n'est
pas un cours d'histoire le siège mais
que des historiens peuvent pas reposer
uniquement sur la mémoire qu'il faut
avoir des sources les archives et dans
la deuxième saison par loin d'un autre
point historique très bien mais oui mais
enfin tu sais quel est le secret enfin
l'or après mais on est en train de le
dire sont les vieux ne vit pas sur les
rangs du coup ça marche pas c'est pas
grave mais bref d'être toujours quand
même un léger dégel réflexion en légère
mais j'ai ramené votre enfant à stang
parce que des histoires en scène pour
parler du 20e siècle
oui enfin dans ces amusants à elle et au
31ème siècle
23 23 ans dans pas longtemps oui oui
attentats il y aura plus d'humains on
sera tous morts
moi j'ai franchement en vrai le 23ème
siècle c'est chaud je pense qu'on va y
arriver
ouais tu joyeux battu les tue bah non
c'est un peu le but est assailli elle
est en train de comprendre mon dieu ça
veut dire qu'elle est tellement qu
rabier nord j'adore sa tête et bim 13
palme
c'est une référence ado mais encore une
fois c'est un peu jusqu'à présent mais
bon l agent a dit un mot schlundt et à
la fin c'est tout à la fin c'est un mot
qui vient de stargate
il me semble et puis florence voulais le
dire oui
et du coup je dis oui peut-être que
c'est l'an passé dans le langage courant
23ème siècle pourquoi pas les normes est
un peu jalouse tout de même j'aime
beaucoup parce que dans tout le reste
des plans guillaume est juste derrière
rien plus rien je suis une planche voilà
du coup on va tous l'ird et guillaume
pour voir s'ils jouent bien la plante
oui oui moi il fait de très bonnes
plantes fait beaucoup de trop rire du
coup on voit dans les lunettes le
réflecteur un petit peu mais déjà dans
les plans dans son bureau en arabe sans
scission à ça et moi levage de dieu
thierry l'appareil on a eu à inventer
une histoire comme d'amour sans une
belle histoire d'amour réalise mais du
coup on l'a pas mise en partie l'univers
étendu
c'est dans les baies teasing d'écrire
des fanfictions si vous
[Rires]
je vais très belle amorce moi vois mon
épaule oui j'aime beaucoup la musique à
ce moment-là trail et futuriste et
triste ensuite comme vous y allez pas
c'est un jour je vais apprendre que le
mépris envers les noirs c'est pas cool
ben dans la saison dans le second non
oui c'est le plus drôle à jouer les
personnages un peu détestable
bon après elle a quand même un bon fond
oui jack sparrow trop tard laquelle
choix patrie et ça c'est du stargate
ouais vraiment en mode je veux dire ce
mot ok votre je veux dire d'accorder
l'entraidé quel bordel à la base là
c'est un fond vert magnifique on était
sûr on est de toute qualité on est
accroupi sur un lit avec un fond vert
derrière on s'est dit c'est moche mais
tant pis ça sera moi je suis
et là guillaume s'est cogné au lieu
nature qu'on va ta tête en fait j'en ai
filmé deux foires et oui andy drouin là
sur le bêtisier on voyait que j'ai
peut-être sur les le bêtisier on voit
que le plan de gauche donc je suis coupé
tout le temps je vais aussi bizarre
pourtant j'avoue que je me rappelle
qu'on voit tout sait et c'est fini du
coup oui le commentaire et terminait par
les hawks j'espère que ça vous a plu
oui j'espère aussi j'ai des rigolos à
faire ben oui ou de subsistance et le
but des commentaires mais aussi des
choses intéressantes à bas si on le sait
bien c'est à vous de choisir de trier
les informations
oui on fera une version que les
conneries et que le nom merci beaucoup
merci des gros bisous oui à bientôt
à bientôt pour la saison 2 oui oui et
sur la chaîne de la prof je sais pas
quand ça s'arrête mais voilà à bientôt
salut salut bisous coup